at the end of this video we're going to
give you the choice of where you want to
travel
are you an idiot mate we're still in
lockdown no no no no not in real life
but we're going to give you and you four
different links to four different
options so you can continue the story
and you can click on whichever one you
like and then decide
wherever you want to go
that was pretty good
sure right
right let's get on with this
remember when we could travel all over
the world
remember when we could just do normal
things like go to the pub i miss it i
know mate i know
but maybe we don't need flight tickets
handfuls of cash and a pandemic free
world to go on an adventure welcome to
miniature wonderland
oh this is a world full of possibilities
it's a world that's really really
uh small
so everything started nearly 20 years
ago my two elder brothers came up with a
lot of very very crazy ideas and one was
to build the world largest model right
away
[Music]
we are in hamburg germany and welcome to
this sprawling model world and it's just
what we need a world of the places we
all wish we could visit a world full of
life uh well i'll let sebastian give you
the details the whole layout is about 1
500 square meter and everything is
connected by rail so we have 16
kilometers of track and about 1 000
trains are going through wonderland
few hundred cars controlled by computer
265 000 small mini inhabitants
30 000 liters of real water and ships
are going around oh my god
[Music]
there are so many parts of the world
[Music]
it's just yeah it's something like a
fairy tale
miniature wonderland holds the world
record for the largest model railway but
it also has another record oh yes this
music is building towards something
spectacular something outrageously cool
and mind bogglingly massive the world's
largest model airport
my personal highlight is the airport
where 42 planes who are computer
controlled and they can take off and
land
but took four million euros and five
years of building
i personally love to be at the airport
and i can watch or follow the plane two
hours
this is our control room this is the
heart of wonderland every train every
car every ship is controlled from here
right
time for you to choose where you want to
go you've got four options
choose well i hope you choose right i'm
gonna go for the city of sin myself um i
think i deserve to be there after
standing in front of the camera like
this and looking like an absolute tool
nice
pick well
[Music]
you